chrissy teigen has shared so much on
social media about the devastating loss
of her baby
it almost feels like we've gone through
this with her but today
seeing chrissy sitting with john for the
first time
made their heartbreak really hit home
it's so painful to go through something
like this as a woman something that was
inside your body that you were nurturing
and taking care of
every day is so different so when people
ask me how i'm doing i always say i'm
okay today
[Music]
the pain is still raw for chrissy and
john less than two months after the
heart-wrenching pregnancy loss
of their 20-week-old baby jack when i
spoke with john earlier this month
he had nothing but praise for his wife i
think chrissy sharing
what she shared has also been helpful to
other people
who are going through it and may go
through it in the future the couple
documented their loss
taking these deeply intimate photos in
today's exclusive interview with gma
chrissy stood behind her decision to
share the heart-wrenching images
i don't care if you were offended or
disgusted i understand it could be that
way for people
it's designed for the people that were
hurting and john was very uncomfortable
uh taking them she felt like really um
that
one of the ways we would carry on jack's
memory was to take pictures of that
moment
i was like worried i was like i don't
want to like commemorate this pain
but the crazy thing about having a
miscarriage
is you don't walk away with anything you
have this emptiness
helping john and chrissy heal
two-year-old miles
four-year-old luna and the love they
share for each other
i just know that i love my wife more
than ever
we've been through so many challenges
together and they've made us stronger
and i know that doesn't always happen
when people go through tragedy
how do you continue to push forward in
such a positive manner
we hold on to the fact that we have two
beautiful kids that we love
we've always loved a very lively
household and i don't know you don't
want to be stuck in bed when you hear
the laughter downstairs it helps so much